when you go into organizations and you
talk to leaders and tell them about
bringing meaning and purpose for their
employees and they tell you oh yeah
we've got a well-being day
yeah organized once a year we've got
that covered yeah like what would you
have to tell them when people say to me
well we have a wellness thing we got
that covered my response is about
consistency versus intensity right so if
you if you stop brushing your teeth and
only go to the dentist twice a year
will your teeth fall out yes they will
right you cannot go to the gym for nine
hours and get into shape but if you work
at every single day for 20 minutes you
absolutely get into shape I just don't
know when
and the reason companies like intensity
is because it's easy to measure we had
the event we hired the speakers we gave
them a certificate check they're all
leaders right but it's the daily little
things it's the not tons and tons of
just innocuous things that is what
builds up they like brushing your teeth
what does brushing your teeth for two
minutes do it does nothing unless you do
it every single day twice a day and it's
consistency that we forget about yes you
need intensity you still got to go to
the dentist but it's this balance of
intensity and consistency and too many
companies think they can solve a problem
with intensity and and I challenge them
to consider the consistency stuff
[Music]